I'm not thinking of anything bad, and I
don't have anything to do with
humans.It's just that behind the scenes of merging, there are maid cafes and things like that.
Even though you took it, you
changed your interest to the exact opposite, you were making
fun of me, who was worshiped by humans in the original world, was
n't it?  It
's funny
[music]
But now there's
no clouds, you
can go buy it yourself
But the food you ate at that time was more delicious I
don't understand why you
should just go home It
was delicious  That's because you were
next to me, and I
know how much I worried you when I heard you were gone and died.  Get along
with me like you
used to I'm sorry I'm
sorry
I'm coming